oh my God shock and fear as a funnel  cloud Roars into sight  one of 35 reported tornadoes to strike  the South Thursday oh my God this will  be on the beside us I Can't Describe is  it all right Montreal caves uncle and at  least five others were killed when a  reported tornado destroyed roughly 40  homes shearing off roofs and shredding  walls  oh I have mercy officials say the same  tornado also ripped through Selma  Alabama while in Greensboro this was my  mom's house y'all this storm in the  Atlanta area was reduced to a pile of  bricks and cinder blocks that stuff can  be fixed but I'm glad nobody got hurt  the roof of this house in Griffin  Georgia landed on a vehicle parked  outside the powerful Gus uprooted trees  and overturned big rigs on highways  across the South there's been millions  of dollars in damage